[Music]
foreign
hi my name is Michael Thomas and I'm the
chief data scientist at catchberg
analytics I am so excited to be teaching
a workshop at this year's posit comp
with my great friend Eric Nance on tools
and tips for building a shiny app that
can thrive in a production environment
and I wanted to talk to you about three
things that I am so excited about for
this Workshop the first is the concept
of modularization so if you've built a
shiny app in the past using a single
app.r script or maybe separate UI and
server scripts you know that those
scripts can get very big very fast and
everything that we will do in this
Workshop will use shiny modules and will
be a great showcase on how to modularize
your code in a way that is much more
concise legible and maintainable we'll
also show you how to get these modules
to talk to each other so that you can
begin to build shiny apps that are truly
ready for a production environment
the second topic that I am so excited
about for this Workshop is deployment
and we know that we can build a great
app that works phenomenally well on our
own machine but what good is that if we
can't share it with end users or a wider
audience there are a lot of different
deployment strategies and techniques
depending on the type of app that you
are building who you need to share it
with and where you need to share it and
this can come down to whether the app is
going to be public facing or private
facing as well and this is one of the
trickiest parts of the whole shiny app
development process and perhaps one of
the parts that gets talked about the
least so we are thrilled to be able to
make this a part of our workshop and
walk you through these different
deployment strategies so that you can
come out of this workshop with a great
understanding of how you will deploy
apps within your own organization or for
your own use case
and the last thing that I'm so excited
about in this Workshop is the fact that
user experience will be a theme around
everything that we do in the workshop
the concept of Defending Your UI will
get talked about how easy is it for
users to take an action within your app
that they can't undo how performant is
your app when multiple users are using
it concurrently we're going to put
ourselves in the shoes of the server
side of our app and think about how
often it's listening or how often it
needs to be listening to users and
actions after all our shiny app could be
housing a complex machine learning model
for running an intensive Bayesian
simulation but depending on how easy it
is for users to navigate the app can
mean the difference between massive
adoption of your app within the
organization or nobody really using it
and all of that hard work going to waste
so we sincerely hope that you join us
for this workshop and we are so excited
to see you in Chicago
hello I'm Eric Nance and I'm so excited
to be teaching a workshop at this year's
posit comp all about tools and
techniques to help you run your shiny
application successfully in production
and here are the top three reasons why I
think you might benefit from this
Workshop across the community you will
find terrific resources centered around
effective shining development best
practices
now after you deploy your application
you might encounter issues that you did
not have happen when it was just you
developing the application you might
find yourself asking hey it worked just
fine on my machine in this Workshop
we're going to tell you about effective
principles that can help you plan for
the unexpected such as effective
profiling of your application's resource
usage the ways that you can
simultaneously simulate hundreds or even
thousands of users accessing your
application at once and affect the
testing strategies from both the back
end and user interface perspectives to
help illuminate issues before your users
encounter them
as your shiny application grows in
complexity you may find it handling many
different tasks all at once which can
lead to degraded performance so in this
Workshop we're going to teach you ways
that you can make your application
actually do less only do what it needs
to do such as tapping into external
resources for data sources or leveraging
apis to help with some additional
processing and ways that you can
organize the way objects are stored in
your application which may greatly
streamline the processing and give your
users that Snappy feeling that you want
them to have when they visit your app
well in this Workshop much like the rest
of the material we're going to go
Hands-On and explore these different
deploying strategies together and look
at the different advantages and perhaps
even pitfalls that you might encounter
throughout these options and you're
going to get hands-on experience with
platforms such as positive connect and
will also explore container technology
for even more flexible options available
to you for deployment I'm really
passionate about enabling shiny users
that take their skills to the next level
especially in this very important area
of successfully running your application
in production
I hope you join me at this year's
posicon for this exciting workshop and
to register just visit posit.co
conference for all the details I hope to
see you there